- Music often defines
the moments of our lives.
We have entire stories built
around certain songs and memories.
And to celebrate that
we like to do something here
called Playlist Shuffle.
(upbeat rock music)
Love it. So we're gonna get the button.
(audience cheers)
Thank you so much!
He's gonna come and here and--
- Look at that.
This is such a fancy button.
- I like that.
- Season four, we're rich!
Okay, here we go.
I'm gonna hit this button
and a song title will appear
on the screen and Jeff
will tell us the story
of why that song is important to him.
I can't wait to see this song.
So let's go.
Let's see who, here's the first one.
(bell dings)
Oh, that's a great song!
Why Luck be a Lady?
- I have this.
Well, Luck be a Lady, you
know, I like that show.
I've seen it on stage now,
you know what it's from?
It's from a Broadway show
- Guys and Dolls?
- Guys and Dolls.
- Yeah.
And in the movie who plays Sky Masterson
and sings that song is Marlon Brando.
And then on the record
"Live at The Sands", which I recommend,
Frank Sinatra, who's this
great, and who sings it.
It's not his character, he's in the movie
but he plays Nathan in Detroit.
He sings it on the thing.
And of course it's Count Macy's Orchestra.
It's a great version of it.
And Young Quincy Jones is conducting it.
- Wait, really?
- Yes.
- I didn't actually get all of that.
That was so much amazing information.
- Isn't that interesting?
Well you gotta get that
album "Live at The Sands".
It's, it's great.
Also Sinatra. It's, it's just great.
But this, but Marlon Brando did it.
And I have a connection
to Marlon Brando and
I'm gonna tell you a story
and you're gonna tell me
is this true or false?
I may be making it up.
Or I may be, it may be true.
- Okay. I like this game.
- Okay, good.
Okay. So Marlon Brando.
Okay. My, you know, the
pinnacle of of acting.
- Okay.
- Got in touch with me.
He knew he, I'd done "The
Fly" and I had done, you know
Jurassic Park, I'd played
some scientists in a couple
of movies.
Jim Watson, who discovered
DNA, I played these--
He got the idea that
'cause he's very interested
he was very interested
in inventive science
and he wanted to pioneer some new ideas.
He got in touch with me, I'll be darned.
He used to leave me messages,
this is Brand Flakes
he would say, and Jeff
come over to my house.
I went over to his house and
in his swimming pool he had,
looked strange.
I went, "Marlon, what's going
on in your swimming pool?"
He said, "Those are electric eels.
I think we could solve the
energy crisis with an idea
I have, electric eels putting
in the pool and that, that'll do it."
Is that story true or false?
- There is no way that's true.
If that's true, someone
needs some medication.
(laughter)
- Well, me, I always need
all the help I can get.
But that story is true. But not to me.
It never happened to me.
I never met Marlon Brando,
but my friend Ed Begley Jr met him.
- That happened?!
- Exactly to Ed that way. Yes.
- He had eels in his pool?
- Electric eels. Yes.
- Alright.
- And Ed thought he, because
he was known for this.
Is he putting me on? Is he testing me?
You know, he does a
great impersonation of me
He'd go ahead, you know, this is the way
we're gonna solve the energy crisis.
Anyway, there's that story.
- Oh my God, I love that story.
That was false answer. Next one.
Here we go.
(bell dings)
Okay. El Dorado
- Well I do love, Erroll Garner was one
of the first jazz pianists I heard about.
'Cause my dad was a fan.
He brought home Misty.
You know, "look at me, I'm as helpless as"
He wrote that Erroll Garner,
plays it beautifully.
But he's current.
He, he writes a song.
He does a song now called El
Dorado that just knocks me out.
You can see him live on YouTube doing it.
But here's a, here's a story.
Is this true or false?
My dad was such a fan
of his in Pittsburgh.
He knew his manager or some, a team
that was conducting a rehearsal
with him in Pittsburgh.
And Erroll Garner said,
I can't practice anymore.
He can't rehearse anymore.
His guy said, why? I need a paper bag.
I need a paper bag.
And they said, well, kid,
kid to my dad can you go out
and get a paper bag?
He did.
He went across the street
to a farmer here something.
Got a paper bag, Erroll Garner.
Then proceeded when he
brought it back to him to take
off his socks and shoes,
put his feet bare feet
in the paper bag and
continued the rehearsal.
That's the story.
Is that true or false?
- I really hope it's true. (laughs)
I really--
- He, here's the answer.
It is true, but not with
my dad and Errol Garner.
(all laugh)
- It's true. Listen to
this. Listen to this.
- I just figured out how you
get away with lying in life.
It's okay. You weave the
truth in there. (laughs)
- Oh yeah, I'm slipping.
No, it happened to Alex Frank
and his father, Alex Frank
who will, you'll see who plays the,
and arranged our song, his
dad that happened to not
with Erroll Garner, with
the great classical pianist
from Canada, Glen Gould,
who was very eccentric
that happened to him in--
- Very eccentric.
- And he wouldn't play
unless he took his feet off
and put him in a paper bag.
- What, what does that mean?
Like why a paper bag and
you'd think it'd be noisy.
Right?
- I don't even know him.
- It's just an interesting thing.
Like if he is playing and then
you have to use your feet.
You'd think you'd hear it.
- Yes,
- You'd definitely feel it, anyway.
- I don't know.
I've never put my feet in a paper bag.
- No. Okay.
That is Jeff Goldblum's Playlist Shuffle,
True or False?
(audience cheers)